let's try to find the center of mass of
a uniform object like a uniform rod and
let's assume this rod is length L and we
want to find the center of mass now
before I begin this calculation you can
probably already guess that it's going
to be exactly in the middle and we'll
verify that but let's first define what
we mean by our center of mass for
discrete particles recall if this was a
sum over all the particles in the system
so we'll take a label j goes from 1 to n
and it was not it was the mass of that j
particle times the position vector of
that j the particle with respect to some
origin and we're dividing that by j goes
from 1 to n of the total mass in the
system now how do we translate this
equation for a continuous system and let
me just again show that we had chosen an
origin here was our jate particle of
mass m j + rj so what we want to do is
draw the analogy and here's how it works
that for each discrete particle we're
going to look at that as some mass
element Delta M J our vector RJ will go
to a vector for this mass element I'll
just write it Delta M and our sum from j
goes from 1 to n is actually going to go
to an integral over the body so let's
see how that looks
so first we'll do it with the total mass
M here we're summing over j from 1 to n
of M J that goes to the integral over
the body now the Delta M when we take
limits because that's what an integral
goes we'll write that as DM so that
becomes a limit over the body and
likewise our sum J
goes from 1 to n of MJ RJ goes to an
integral over the body of DM vector are
going to that element so we can say in
the limit that this becomes our going to
that element now that means that our
continuous expression for the continuous
object is an integral over the body of
DM are to that element DM divided by an
integral over the body of DM